il ya quelques jours je vous ai parlé de
la nouvelle surface pro 6 2 microsoft
aujourd'hui géré notre premier vous
présenter de chez microsoft je sais pas
si vous l'avez vu il était sorti à bhl
il ya quelques temps c'est la surface
laptop de c'est la deuxième version de
la surface laptop
forcément ces numéros de vous l'aurez
compris et il se trouve vraiment bien
avec une toute nouvelle couleur coloris
noir hyperclasse hyper élégant vraiment
très très bon ordinateur je trouve que
les finitions sont vraiment superbes je
vous montre ça vous allez me dire ce que
vous en pensez en komona parce que moi
je trouve vraiment à raison
[Musique]
on connaît microsoft qui arrive toujours
toujours de jolis produits et que ce
surface laptop 2 c'est exactement la
même chose
regardez ça le design est hyper classe
au dessus vous avez juste petit logo
microsoft comme ça qui est hyper jolie
dans cette couleur noire l hyper
élégante
vous n'avez strictement aucune vis
apparentes tout est vraiment bien
intégré c'est vraiment hyper sympa la
collective dont je vous en parlais dans
quelques instants
le design est très très profilé en
termes de poids n'est pas trop long elle
fait un petit kilo deux bons ce qui est
franchement correct on a un boîtier qui
complètement en aluminium hyperclasse
hyper premium et quand on l'apprend vont
être une sensation de robustesse de
solidité de sérieux et ça c'est vraiment
bien
il se trouve que une fois de plus
microsoft nous fait vraiment un produit
qui est très beau et de très bonne
facture ce qui est vachement intéressant
avec cet ordinateur c'est que vous
pouvez l'utiliser aussi bien un
ordinateur standard appelé c'est bon
c'est un pc de toute façon un petit peu
standard dont vous pouvez l'utiliser
comme ça ça marchera parfaitement bien
mais il ya aussi un écran tactile dont
vous pouvez l'utiliser au doigt pour
venir naviguer faire ce que vous voulez
donc ça c'est aussi vraiment vraiment sa
part et en plus de ça vous pouvez venir
utiliser le surface peines pour venir
dessiner si vous êtes graphiste ou si
vous aimez utiliser un stylet vous
pouvez le faire ça marche parfaitement
bien c'est un peu un 3 en termes
d'utilisation ça peut avoir un sens ça
dépend de votre profession dépend de vos
usages mais je trouve que c'est bien
parce que vous avez des possibilités
vous faites ce que vous voulez comme
vous voulez en gros ça nordique à
pouvoir s'adapter réellement à votre
façon de fonctionner l'ouverture est
hyper facile vous avez un écran qui est
complètement tactile que tactile marche
super bien
hyper facile à utiliser pour naviguer
c'est franchement hyper agréable c'est
un écran de 13,5 pouces de diagonale
avec une résolution de 2256 pas 1504
pixels à 200 pixels par pouces à l'avant
vous avez un corning gorilla glass 3
c'est un écran pixel cesse et comme je
vous le disais peut être utilisé aussi
bien avec vos doigts et stylet quel est
votre souhait enfin vous faites vraiment
ce que vous voulez comme vous voulez
trouve que c'est un écran qui est assez
lumineux
la colorimétrie vraiment correct les
couleurs sont très bien rendus pourra
peut-être un peu négatif c'est qu'on a
quand même des grandes bordure noire
tout autour alors qu'on va plus sur des
produits notamment des ordinateurs avec
des bordures toujours plus fine et les
caméras toujours mieux intégrer là on a
quand même une grande bordure noire
c'est pas forcément kyler elle vous
permet à près de loger votre petite
caméra ici je vous en reparle dans
quelques instants
mais bon c'est vrai qu'en termes
d'esthétique
on aurait pu apprécier que microsoft
vient d'un petit peu corrigé ce pont en
tout cas améliorer avec des bords un peu
plus fils s'arrêtera peut-être de gagner
même type en termes de dimensions au
niveau du châssis
bon c'est un point de détail mais il
fallait le mentionner un des usages
important cet ordinateur c'est l'aspect
multimédia pour me regarder des séries
des films profiter de ce que vous voulez
ça marche bien il ya un son qui est de
bonne qualité avec des haut-parleurs qui
sont cachés souvent de clavières on a
des haut parleurs omni sonic avec dolby
audio l'expérience sonore et bien on n'a
pas des gros grave qui ronronne on n'a
pas un truc qui est complètement fou
mais par contre on a une expérience
audio qui as et qualitative
quand on se met bien en face qui est
assez immersive et qui est correct somme
toute sur un ordinateur comme ça après
je sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
on a deux sus une prise jack aller
planquer juste là sur le côté la prise
dock est intéressante et vous restitue
un son de qualité
lorsque vous voulez l'écouté au casque
parce que bon des fois on peut pas
toujours écoutés avec lé haut parleurs à
fond si vous êtes par exemple dans un
travail que vous voulez vous mettre une
petite série par contre je trouve
cocasse qu le speck sera meilleur on
aura plus de sons qui ronronne on
profitera d'une meilleure qualité audio
leur attention ça ça dépend bien
évidemment de votre casque si vous avez
un casque de bonne qualité l'audio va
être cool si le casque est pas terrible
ça sympa car il s'agit mais dormi mais
par contre c'est vrai que dans un point
de vue multimédia au niveau de cet écran
sud ali psa on n'est pas sûr du hall n b
du point de vue purement multimédia
visionnage de contenus vidéo que ce soit
sur youtube soit sur netflix que ça vous
voulez ça marche bien l'audio sympa au
casque ça marche bien sur le haut
parleur principal ça va donc mal absolu
est ce que cette surface latok 2 pour
regarder du multimédia et bien la
réponse est oui
qu'en est il maintenant au niveau du
clavier alors c'est pas là vous allez
voir là la course la plus courte au
niveau des touches par contre vous c'est
bien le retour de touche est vraiment
correct le clavier en lumens et bien il
est suffisamment grand
les touches sont suffisamment grands
noms galère pas alors ça dépend bien
évidemment que sur la taille de vos
doigts je trouve que le clavier en
lui-même est bien réussie de la part de
microsoft
autre point qui est intéressant c'est le
trackpad il est pas hyper hyper grands
ont contre regarde comme ça notamment en
étant habitué à macbook pro avec un
trackpad est quand même beaucoup plus
grand néanmoins il est bien sûr tout il
ya un pas qui est vraiment très positif
par rapport à un macbook pro c'est vous
pouvez venir poser un petit peu votre
main la venir naviguer ça passe pas de
problème ça c'est le gros défaut du
macbook pro c'est comme votre trackpad
il arrive vraiment au bord qui vous
posent à peine votre mal à
et bien tout de suite ça va venir
toucher le bar du trackpad et ça peut
rapidement posé problème ça par contre
c'est bien pouvait le faire autrefois
qui vraiment bien plus comment ils sont
d'alcantara on a touché qui est hyper
nous je trouve ça hyper relaxant dans
eiffage vous travaillez vous êtes
stressé vous posez votre main vous
caressez l'alcantara
ça fait un bien fou maintenant il ya peu
je suis un peu dubitatif c'était la même
chose avec la surface pro c'est la
connectique vous avez de l'usb standard
vous avez une prise jack bien évidemment
vous avez un mini-port display et vous
avez un port surface connect et c'est
tout absolument tout ils ne l'ont pas
mal de choses sur cette machine déjà
n'ya pas d'usb ces sages avaient
reproché la dernière fois la surface pro
l'usbc devient un standard tous connecte
en usb c'est tout quasiment tous là
c'est un petit peu dommage
là on est sur des porcs propriétaire
microsoft microsoft cherche pas à
s'ouvrir c'est surprenant parce que la
marque souvent qu'il ne s'ouvre pas
c'est apple apple s'est ouvert avec de
l'usb s'est passé d'ailleurs tout usb
c'est là on a toujours l'espoir
propriétaire microsoft ça pourrait
paraître logique que microsoft bascule
également vers l'usb c'est que ce soit
pour la recharge pour avoir un sens ça
pourrait être vraiment bien pour quoi
nous mettre de l'usb et pourquoi pas
l'usb c'est pourquoi pas d'ailleurs
mettre un petit dock comment on peut
retrouver notamment chez apple avec
ensuite pas mal de porc intéressant
notamment du hdmi il n'y a pas d'âge des
amis là dessus on n'a pas non plus de
lecteurs carte microsd ça pourrait être
intéressant notamment pour des créateurs
de contenus ou des photographes
lorsque vous avez votre cas vous avez
bien possible vous venez la décharge est
directement ça ce sont des petits bémols
j'espère néanmoins que ça pourrait être
corrigé dans la prochaine version de
cette bécane peut-être en dominant à
côté de sakho et du performance c'est
vraiment une bonne machine vous avez un
intel core i7 ou i5 de huitième
génération ça vous fait donc une machine
qui est un peu plus performante que la
machine de la génération précédente vous
avez soit 8 gigas de ram soit 16 giga de
ram
côté graphique c'est une nuage des
graphiques 620 qui fonctionnera
également parfaitement bien j'ai rien
trouvé de particulier à dire de point de
vue graphique d'un point de vue
performances ça marche bien ça dépendra
toujours bien évidemment de vos usages
des logiciels que vous allez faire
tourner dessus
si vous avez des logiciels qui sont très
gourmands mais il a fallu remonter dans
les configurations un peu supérieurs de
l'icet avec 16 giga de ram ça serait pas
un luxe
si vous faites de la ville de toute
façon c'est le strict minimum sous
photoshop de la même manière si vous
faites du multi cac je conseille
vraiment monter un grand minima sur le
16 giga de ram c'est dommage d'être un
petit peu le peut être frustrant sans
cette bécane là c'est de se dire que
on n'a pas de configuration 32 gigas de
ram ça aurait pu avoir un sens sont dit
si vous faites de la vidéo ça serait
vraiment bien
voilà bon ça c'est pas possible c'est un
petit peu un point de regrets à côté de
ça on est sur une machine qui est quand
même relativement silencieuse qui je
trouve ne chauffe pas particulièrement
un peu si vous venez poser votre main
dessus après des séances un petit peu
endurant pour mon test j'ai une version
qui m'a été envoyé avec un intel core i5
8 gigas de ram et 256 giga de stockage
j'ai pas la config la plus performante
mais pour ce que j'en ai fait ça marche
bien ça je pense qu'on est vraiment sur
une machine faite pour de la bureautique
ça que j'ai en tout cas là le 8 gigas de
ram 1500 vidéo ça sera quand même
relativement moins ça photoshop
ok n'aurait pas grand choses dessus
après on est quand même sur une bécane
qui est vraiment donner plus pour
l'aspect personnel familial je dirais ou
à leur travail mais travaille pas avec
des logiciels hyper gourmand plus de la
bureautique
là où tu sauras vrai sens c'est plus une
machine que vous allez utiliser la
journée pour le travail le soir pour du
multimédia et son écran ça ça ira
parfaitement bien a noté vous avez en
termes de stockage soit une version 128
go de stockage 256 512 ou alors
carrément intérêts et tout ça bien
évidemment un ssd microsoft nous annonce
une autonomie allant jusqu'à 14,5 heures
alors les 14 5 heures très précisément
chronomètre en main je les ai pas
trouvés j'ai un petit peu moins de 10
heures entre 9h et 10h c'est à peu près
ce que ce que j'arrive à avoir d'autant
plus que je vous dis là dessus c'est pas
du tout une machine de fête pour un
travail hyper hyper hyper exigeants en
termes de performances sur mon i
s'accuser drame
donc bon voilà je n'ai plus fait du côté
bureautique du côté multimédia en gros
j'utilise pour une journée complète le
matin lorsque je parle utilisation elle
est complètement chargé donc tout ce qui
va être bureautique travaille pas besoin
de batterie vous arriver jusqu'au soir
vous êtes tranquilles après si vous
poussez vraiment au niveau des séries
soirée vous allez vraiment vraiment loin
peut-être asma falloir lui mettre un
petit coup de recharge mais ce nom dans
l'absolu pas besoin l'autonomie est
vraiment bonne
vous profitez bien évidemment là dessus
d'un windows dix familles qui fonctionne
bien bombasse à l'apparence d'ailleurs
dessus vous avez bien évidemment windows
et l'eau arrive au petit soin de
qualifier en 720 pixels qui vous
permettra de le déverrouiller très
facilement ça c'est un côté qui est
vraiment pratique on peut être regretter
qui épate de 14 empreintes digitales
pour ce que pas forcément envie
d'utiliser la caméra qui veulent poser
votre doigt la bourbince et c'est un
point de détail point qui est
intéressant vous avez des micro stéréo
lorsque vous voulez faire de la
visioconférence notamment à skype qui
fait partie de l'écosystème microsoft
votre petite caméra vos petits micros
pour faire de la conf call à distance ça
peut avoir un sens pointu sécurité vous
avez la puce tpm 2.0 je vous disais vous
avez windows et l'eau pour la
reconnaissance de votre visage qui
marche parfaitement bien mais vous avez
également du wifi bien évidemment vous
vous en douterez et du bluetooth 4
points dans cette machine allait bien
belle elle a forcément un prix combien
est ce qu'elle coûte alors je vous met
dans le mille une fois de plus a priori
parker ya pas mal de choses comme je le
disais vous avez une configuration en
pneus à tiroirs configurations multiples
je vous donnais les tarifs que j'ai pris
bien évidemment sur le site de microsoft
à l'heure à laquelle bien évidemment je
tourne la vidéo alors pour le intel core
i5 8 gigas de ram 128 g n et stockage
c'est la version la plus petite goutte
1149 euros
très clairement je vous déconseille
d'une version 128 go de stockage pour
moi toujours un petit peu trop restreint
si vous stockez forcément dans votre
machine
si vous allez stocker quelques vidéos
des photos vous mettez de la musique et
pas mal de logiciels à un moment vous
risquez de manquer de place donc je vous
déconseille fortement une version 128
giga pour mâles grand minimum ses 256
giga donc on prend la même config lee 5
8 gigas de ram 256 giga on est à 1449 le
rhône un petit peu moins de 1500 euros
pourriez tout ce tollé sur une bécane
d'où le prix y est quand même
relativement élevé on arrive ensuite sur
le i7 toujours 8 gigas de ram 256 go de
stockage 1749 euros
et après on monte davantage il cède 16
giga de ram 512 giga de stockage 2349
euros ça commence à faire mal et ensuite
il cède 16 giga de ram un terrain de
stockage 2849 vous voyez qu'on est quand
même sur des tarifs entre 1149 et 2849
c'est quand même une machine qui est à
un prix relativement élevés c'est la
politique tarifaire microsoft ils ont
aussi des produits par contre
d'excellente qualité
le produit extrêmement bien fini très
beau très robuste avec un écran tactile
bon on n'a rien à lui reprocher de ce
point de vue là mais c'est vrai que par
rapport à la concurrence sur des
produits qui pourraient être
sensiblement équivalent en france
notamment sur du mi5 qui sera moins cher
on n'aura peut être pas les mêmes
finitions n'aura pas le goût microsoft
n'aura peut-être pas la même qualité que
ce produit là mais je me mets à la place
du consommateur en disant alors à quand
même
on en produit je veux acheter j'ai un
budget est tout de suite loyers ont
toutes un petit budget un petit peu
élevé je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
moi je trouve par contre vraiment bien
se produit toujours regretter c'est le
fait que on n'est pas du sbc fossé tout
de suite un petit peu limitatif
au delà du côté durban port usb ce
serait la machine en elle-même est
vraiment bien l'expérience et bien c'est
une belle décale qui donne vraiment
sensation de robustesse qui est hyper
classe cette couleur noire en plus elle
est hyper jolie donc moi je trouve que
c'est vraiment un produit qui a vraiment
du potentiel et qui est vraiment
intéressant je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez est ce que vous l'avez acheté
vous cette surface laptop v2 comment
vous la trouvez est-ce que vous la
trouvez intéressante est ce que vous
aimez en règle générale les produits de
microsoft est ce que vous aimez cette
finition garder nos salles ça je trouve
ça bouge stocks qui touchait alcantara
ça commence à vraiment bien on a
vraiment un ordi très bien mais si vous
voulez donc je comprends aussi que le
prix se justifie
alors si vous intéresse je vous ai mis
un lien oublier en bas dans la
description dites moi ce que vous en
pensez
comment vous le trouvez vous marquez
tout ça en bas en commentaires questions
interrogations suggestions tout ce que
vous voulez il donne rendez vous dès
demain pour continuer à parler texte
s'embrassent courent
soyez sages à bientôt ciao